on Wednesday Pete Davidson was spotted
in New York City for the first time
since he and ariana grande called off
their engagement the 24 year old
Saturday Night Live star looked somber
as he was photographed sporting a black
and red echo unlimited sweat suit has he
gotten to his mercedes-benz with a
friend while the comedians AG tattoo was
still visible on his right thumb the
dangerous woman singer covered her peep
finger tat with a band-aid at a
pre-taped performance in the upcoming
wicked musical special Davidson was
scheduled to make an appearance at
Temple University's comedy night live on
Wednesday but in the wake of his breakup
with Grande he dropped out due to quote
personal reasons news broke of the
couple's split on Sunday a day after the
former Nickelodeon star dropped out of
her scheduled performance at a charity
event in LA on Saturday her manager
Scooter Braun broke the news to the
crowd you saw your invite somewhat I'm
very close to it was supposed to come
sing for you today and because of things
that she's going through she couldn't be
here today and while I was frustrated
being the manager my wife being who she
always is just looked at me and she goes
she needs this time if people are coming
to see her sing and not doting to the
Cancer Foundation I don't want them
there anyway a source previously told et
that the popstar was the one to end
their engagement quote ariana made the
final decision and Pete is incredibly
heartbroken Pete is still so in love
with her he wanted his whole world to
revolve around her but she was
emotionally unavailable the source added
quote he realizes she was at her limit
with pressure from everyone and
everything around her Pete had to give
her that space out of love Ariana and
Pete got engaged in June after just
weeks of dating yeah I'm lucky and just
be crying like out of happiness
literally lately I was on FaceTime last
night crying you're like are you okay
you know like yeah
franki grande approve of Pete is the
question listen my sister super happy
so I prove she even wrote a song for him
appropriately titled Davidson but the
engaged bliss took a hit when Ariana's
ex-boyfriend Mac Miller died suddenly in
September
[Music]
grande has since returned her engagement
ring but is keeping their pet pig piggy
smalls she also took to Instagram to let
her devoted fans know that she was
taking a break from social media but
later posted videos of her Pig
[Music]